ya nos hemos encontrado en varias
ocasiones con la situación en la que
haya un parámetro asociado a una
población quizá la proporción de una
población que apoya a un candidato quizá
es una media de la población la estatura
media de todos los habitantes de alguna
ciudad está claro que en general es sin
práctico o imposible conocer el valor
actual del parámetro poblacional pero
podemos estimar lo al tomar una muestra
de tamaño n a partir de la cual
calculamos un estadístico también hemos
visto que no tan solo calculamos el
estadístico para estimar un parámetro
sino que también podemos construir un
intervalo de confianza centrado en ese
estadístico con base en cierto nivel de
confianza de tal manera que el intervalo
de confianza se verá más o menos así
será el valor del estadístico que
acabamos de calcular más o menos un
margen de error dado por un valor
crítico z el cual estará determinado por
el número de desviaciones estándar que
queremos considerar por arriba y por
abajo del estadístico así que
multiplicamos esto por la desviación
estándar de la distribución muestral del
estadístico por lo general no conocemos
esto pues para conocerlo
queríamos conocer el parámetro real por
ejemplo en el caso en el que el
parámetro que queremos estimar y para el
cual queremos construir intervalos de
confianza sea la proporción poblacional
digamos qué proporción de la población
apoya a cierto candidato en este caso el
estadístico es la proporción muestral
tenemos entonces la proporción muestral
más menos zeta estrella x no podemos
calcular esto a menos que conozcamos la
proporción poblacional en lugar de eso
lo estimamos con el error estándar del
estadístico el cual en este caso es la
raíz cuadrada de p sombrero por uno
menos p sombrero sobre el tamaño de la
muestra si el parámetro que queremos
estimar es la media poblacional entonces
nuestro estadístico será la media
muestral en este caso lo que tendremos
es nuestro estadístico la media muestral
más menos se está estrella ahora si
conociéramos la desviación estándar de
esta población podemos calcular la
desviación estándar de nuestro
estadístico la cual es igual a la
desviación estándar de la población
sobre la raíz cuadrada de nuestro tamaño
muestral pero x
general no conocemos esto es muy raro
poder conocer este valor por lo que dado
que no conocemos esto calculemos
entonces la desviación estándar de
nuestra muestra por lo cual tendremos
más bien la media muestral más menos se
está estrella por la desviación estándar
de la muestra que podemos calcular
dividida entre la raíz cuadrada de n
ahora esto parece correcto si lo que
queremos es construir un intervalo de
confianza para nuestra media pero sucede
que esto no es correcto pues esto de
aquí va de hecho a subestimar el
intervalo real el verdadero margen de
error que se requiere para el nivel de
confianza establecido es por esto que
los especialistas en estadística han
inventado otro estadístico en vez de
usar z usan el que han llamado t y en
vez de usar una tabla zeta usan una
tabla te vamos a seguir hablando de esto
en futuros vídeos es decir si lo que
quieren es construir un intervalo de
confianza con base en la media muestral
y no conocen el valor de la desviación
estándar de la población lo cual en
general es el caso en vez de hacer esto
lo que vamos a hacer
es tomar nuestra media poblacional más
menos y ahora a nuestro valor crítico lo
llamaremos de estrella multiplicado por
la desviación estándar de la muestra que
podemos calcular dividida entre la raíz
cuadrada de n
así que la diferencia al usar esta
expresión es que si corresponde al nivel
de confianza requerido si queremos un
intervalo de confianza del 95% si
continuamos calculando esto varias veces
para muchas muestras aproximadamente el
95% de las veces estos intervalos
contendrán el valor real de nuestra
media poblacional en la práctica y esto
lo veremos en futuros vídeos simplemente
tenemos que usar la tabla t en lugar de
la tabla zeta nos vemos en el próximo
vídeo